[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce 22 décembre
ils sont presque en retard les
préparatifs pour les fêtes de fin
d'année se poursuivre dans les magasins
à quelques heures de noël
nous nous sommes rendus dans plusieurs
commerces de saint quentin en yvelines
pour suivre le dernier rush de l'année
deux ministres à candidats de candidats
à président emmanuel macron et son
mouvement de la république en marche ont
réalisé une percée politique inédite en
2017 pour évoquer cette année qui paraît
être si particulière shine escalettes
sera notre invité fil rouge la référente
et l'hérault m dans les yvelines
dans le reste de l'actualité retour sur
la mise en commun du dispositif hivernal
pour la voirie des départements des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine ou encore
l'inauguration d'un bâtiment gériatrique
à l'hôpital de plaisir noël c'est donc
ce dimanche vous êtes sûrement en train
de vous préparer faire à manger chercher
le meilleur la meilleure tenue
les magasins eux font face à un raz de
marée de clients près de trois français
sur dix achètent chaque année leurs
cadeaux lors de la dernière semaine
forcément lucratif pour les magasins qui
enregistre à cette période précisément
20% de leur chiffre d'affaires de noël
des courses de dernière minute qu'a pu
suivre et constaté michael et demi
d'euros à saint quentin en yvelines
thomas bach ou 1,21 nom a profité de sa
pause déjeuner pour faire un détour au
magasin de jouets de montigny le
bretonneux
son objectif trouver un cadeau pour son
cousin à quelques heures de noël
j'aime bien me prendre à la dernière
minute à noël c'est pas très
représentatif pour moi donc
donc j'ai fait jamais vraiment guère
fait plus juste avant je me dis que ce
serait bien que j'achète quelque chose
donc je vais toujours de la même façon
et je pense que c'est pas prêt changé au
total ce sont trois français sur 10 qui
viennent acheter leurs cadeaux la
dernière semaine
un achat de dernière minute qui peut
ressembler à un véritable casse tête
pour les clients elle fait patienter les
fans comme ça on est de la choisir en
même temps qu'est ce que son fils il
aimerait sa fille des enfants on échange
les idées qu en fait parce que c'est pas
évident ils ont tous les enfants
aujourd'hui je voulais que je quand même
pressé
avoir un casse-tête également pour les
boutiques ce magasin de jouets qui
enregistre 15 % de clients
supplémentaires dans les derniers jours
se retrouvent en rupture de stock sur
plusieurs produits
1 trois jours de noël bien sûr il ya la
rupture sur certains produits ça c'est
sûr donc après soit on continue à
chercher désespérément chose dans cette
chocolaterie de montigny le bretonneux
c'est également la course aux derniers
achats de noël
cette période de l'année représente 50%
du chiffre d'affaires annuel de la
boutique avec des pics à 15000 euros la
journée beaucoup plus de monde donc on
est quand même hier on était sur une
journée à 180 clients jours aujourd'hui
je pense qu'on va faire à peu près 200
clients jour demain on va faire 220 à
230 et jusqu'au samedi comme ça on va
monter presque à 300 clients jours
derniers achats programmés pour ce week
end la carte bleue risque encore de
chauffer alors voilà pour vous souhaite
de bonnes fêtes de noël
à bientôt monsieur en bref dont
l'actualité une cinquantaine de salariés
à manifester jeudi à trappes devant
l'hôpital privé de l'ouest parisien
des salariés qui s'opposent à la
délocalisation dans le val d'oise des
services des ressources humaines et
comptabilité de l'établissement un
déplacement qui devraient concerner neuf
salariés de l'hôpital trappistes
au chapitre politique les élus
départementaux ne sont pas encore en
vacances ils voter ce vendredi à
versailles les dernières mesures 2017 en
conseil départemental à l'ordre du jour
notamment elles la réforme de la
restauration scolaire pour les collèges
yvelinois mais surtout le débat
d'orientation budgétaire un débat suivi
par nicolas landry sur place pour les
précisions hausse des investissements
maîtrise des dépenses de fonctionnement
et augmentation des recettes fiscales
par rapport à 2010 est ce sont les trois
tendances qui ressortent de
l'orientation budgétaire du département
voté ce matin en séance près de 300
millions d'euros de dépenses
d'investissement prévues notamment pour
la construction de routes
la rénovation de collège ou encore pour
aider les communes concernant les
dépenses de fonctionnement si le rsa
l'apa et la pch
semble augmenter l'aide sociale à
l'hébergement devrait connaître une
baisse sur le volet fiscal la hausse des
recettes s'explique par l'augmentation
de près de 10% du droit de mutation à
titre onéreux notamment grâce au
dynamisme du marché de l'immobilier
mais écoutez pierre bédier justifier ces
évolutions alors ces droits de mutation
sont proportionnelles au nombre de
mutations donc là aussi le tour
n'augmente pas mais les transactions
augmente dans les dépenses sociales
il y en a qu'on maîtrise il y en a qu'on
ne maîtrise pas le vieillissement ne
maîtrise pas par définition mais il y en
a d'autres où effectivement rationalise
les dépenses autre sujet abordé lors de
cette séance le changement de la gestion
du service de restauration à travers une
société d'économie mixte à opérateur
unique c'est à dire que le département
veut faire appel à une entreprise pour
gérer ce service public
une réforme qui rencontre l'opposition
des syndicats comme vous le voyez à
l'image
ce matin ils étaient mobilisés devant le
conseil départemental lors de la séance
autre point aussi des plans de
rénovation urbaine ou encore des aides
exceptionnelles attribuées aux communes
certains disent que cette année marquée
marquera un tournant politique pour
notre pays avec la mise à mal des partis
traditionnels qu'ils soient de gauche ou
de droite et l'élection du président le
plus jeune de la vème république
jamais élue auparavant d'autres
critiquent ce semblant de nouveautés et
s'inquiète de l'exercice du pouvoir par
un président qui décideraient de tout
pour revenir sur cette année politique
2010 est si riche en surprises shine et
7 à la bête avec nous en plateau bonsoir
on ça vous est la référente de la
république en marche pour les yvelines
quel regard vous portez vous sur cette
année politique
vous avez rejoint très tôt le
en marche dès sa formation est ce que
vous pensiez concrètement il y a un an
tout juste en décembre 2016 que vous
seriez là dans cette situation un an
plus tard et ce que vous pensiez
vraiment ou alors c'est vous avez vous
même été surprise par la tournure des
événements alors je dirais pas que je
pensais que je serais là à ce moment
précis avec vous aujourd'hui ce soir
mais je pensais qu'il se passait quelque
chose et que nous étions en plein
renouveau les français en avaient assez
de l'ancien monde politique du clivage
gauche droite
ce que les français voulaient vraiment
et souhaitait vraiment s'était
transformé en profondeur la france et
puis faire en sorte de révolutionner de
rabattre les cartes du paysage politique
et là je me suis dit il se passe quelque
chose et je vous savez ça allait aller
aussi loin à ce point à ce point là on
vous le parler des anciens du vieux
monde politique qui sont aujourd'hui
encore pour certains dans le monde
politique mais ils ont quasiment tous
disparu il ya un an quand on se parlait
peut-être quand on parlait de politique
c'était françois fillon le favori
aujourd'hui qui sait ce que fait
françois fillon effectivement moi je
pense que le monde politique ancien est
trop rester dans l'autre soit il on
était dans une logique beaucoup trop par
individu à liszt est dans une logique
d'élection de penser à leur réélection
alors que les français avaient besoin
qu'on leur parle qu'on s'intéresse à
leurs problématiques et l'idée vraiment
c'est que le mouvement en marche est
allé à la rencontre des citoyens et des
citoyennes en leur disant mais qu'est ce
que vous avez à nous dire concernant les
problèmes de la france
ça a été l'opération de la grande marche
donc une opération de porte à porte qui
a permis de dresser un état des lieux
index de chansons alors tu as fait que
ça a basculé un moment je pense que
l'élément déclencheur ça a été renouer
le lien est allé l'écouter tout un
chacun sur le terrain pour lui dire et
qu'est ce qui marche en france
et qu'est ce qui ne marche pas et s'il y
avait une chose a changé
qu'est ce que ce serait
alors quand vous regardez cette année
2010 est est ce que vous dites pas
parfois c'est un peu trop toutes ces
victoires électorales toutes ces
réformes lancées cette image d' emmanuel
macron avec des sondages qui se porte
aujourd'hui très bien cette image aussi
positive au niveau de l'union européenne
au niveau international aujourd'hui il
représente quelque chose on le sort est
ce que vous dites pas un moment
forcément ça va se retourner ça peut pas
durer 50 c'est ce que vous préparer à
des lendemains
quand même un peu plus compliqué alors
on se prépare à tout mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que clairement on a
véritablement fait une révolution dans
le paysage politique est hélas qu'on a
vraiment changé
c'est de faire ce que l'on a dit et
c'est ça qui est qui est important et
c'est pour ça que emmanuel macron a
justement une conjoncture positive un
alignement des planètes qui perdure mais
parce qu'il fait ce qu'il a dit il
engage des réformes qui vont dans
l'intérêt des français et qui vont
transformer la vie de tout à chacun et
notamment ses réformes matière de
pouvoir d'achat alors l'heureux le
renouveau s'arrêter parce que le mot de
l'année 2010 est en tout cas d'un point
de vue politique certains disent que le
renouveau c'est pas forcément pour tout
de suite
finalement qu'ils soient politiques
intellectuels spécialiste de la
politique on entend cette musique etc
emmanuel macron applique le pouvoir de
tout en haut comme un chef et que ça
c'est une très vieille méthode politique
qu'on retrouve dans la vème république
dès son départ je vous propose
d'ailleurs d'écouter stéphane mention il
est professeur de droit levé est ce qu
il était sur notre plateau c'était jeudi
soir que ce président de la république
très jeune renou aux fêtes semble
renouer avec la lettre de la
constitution de la vème république avec
une pratique assez assez gaullienne
finalement des institutions avec un
président jupitérien c'est-à-dire un
président qui s'occupe de l'essentiel
qui est censée ne s'occuper que de
l'essentiel faire et certains lui
reprochent d
et de ressusciter quelques pratiques
anciennes au niveau politique un
président qui s'occupe surtout de
politique extérieure au point que le
ministre des affaires étrangères qui est
pourtant une personnalité assez forte
monsieur le drian n'apparaît que très
secondairement et puis un président qui
s'occupe aussi de défense nationale de
l'armée etc
donc voilà des pratiques renouvelée mais
finalement dans un cadre très
traditionnel comment vous jugez cette
analyse du changement qui est un peu
paradoxale parfois chez emmanuel macron
c'est pas pour tous les étages on va
dire de la politique macro nien moi je
pense qu'il ya un véritable changement à
tous les niveaux alors quand on regarde
l'assemblée nationale avec le
renouvellement des visages le
renouvellement des pratiques des
personnes novices en politique c'est
quelque chose qui a qui ne s'est jamais
vu depuis des années et c'est vraiment
ça le le renouveau par rapport à tout ça
mais aussi ce qui est important de
savoir c'est qu emmanuel macron change
les pratiques et surprend il surprend
voyait disais oui il est il renouvelle
les pratiques mais en même temps dans un
cadre traditionnel c'est parce que la
france a tellement été ancrée dans un
cadre tellement gauche droite et c'est
que le fait d'avoir des nouvelles
pratiques dans ce système qui n'existera
plus dont les mois les années à venir
pose problème et les gens se disent est
ce que ça a vraiment changé
ou pas je vous confirme que ça a
vraiment changé maintenant des personnes
canalisées
le monde politique antérieure peuvent se
dire peut-être que c'est juste il faut
qu'on prenne le temps aussi de se
réformer intellectuellement exact on a
vu quelques critiques récemment au sein
de votre propre camp jamais dire les
premières de l'ère macron sur le projet
de loi sur l'immigration et l'asile
vous qui êtes une ancienne des jeunes
socialistes est ce que vous êtes
attentif par exemple parce qu'il peut se
faire sur ce sujet là
les mesures concrètes en valais on va
les voir se dévoiler en 2018 est ce que
ça pourrait être une ligne de fracture
pour vous si si ça va trop loin
ce projet de loi moi ce que je voudrais
reposer c'est le débat par rapport à ce
projet de loi ce qui est important c'est
que aujourd'hui le premier ministre est
dans un temps de discussion et des coûte
il a rencontré cet après midi pendant
plus de deux heures avec le premier
intérieur gérard collomb avec agnès
buzyn et avec également julian normandie
pendant de plus de deux heures donc
c'est ça ces associations d'hébergement
d'urgence et de demandeurs d'asile pour
revenir sur les contours de la fameuse
circulaire et du projet de loi alors sur
les contours de la circulaire ce qui est
important c'est de préciser que bien
évidemment l'inconditionnalité de
l'accueil n'est pas remis en cause ça
c'est le premier point le second point
qui a été qui a fait polémique et qui a
été je pense un peu mal compris c'est la
façon dont on va travailler
l'objectif ce n'est pas de faire le tri
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir mieux
accompagner dans des conditions beaucoup
plus dit les demandeurs d'asile et est
donc c'est ça qui est important c'est ce
que tu me retenir s'il faudra aussi
peut-être faire un peu plus de pédagogie
mais en tout cas selon vous on l'a bien
compris pas de ligne de fracture sur ce
sujet là au sein de la république en
marche nous après je peux résumer en un
mot c'est en fait l'idée c'est de mieux
intégrer les demandeurs d'asile mieux
intègre également les réfugiés et faire
en sorte de rendre les dispositifs pour
les situations irrégulières beaucoup
plus efficace alors là on a beaucoup on
a beaucoup parlé de national localement
dans les yvelines
onze députés sur douze seulement un
sénateur sur six ça veut dire quoi bilan
mitigé ou alors vous restez quand même
penché sur les législatives et vous
dites que cette année est excellente
pour vous dans le département
ulta politiques sont très encourageants
en fait les députés ont été élus par
l'ensemble des citoyens qui souhaitent
un renouvellement que les choses
changent que l'on transforme la
politique que le groupe las justement le
citoyen au coeur du débat politique et
l'élection des députés s'étaient cette
image là la nouvelle façon de faire de
la politique ce que les français veulent
mettre fin à l'ancien système
en revanche pour les élections
sénatoriales c'était une autre donne ses
tâches que ce sont les grands électeurs
et les élus d'avant en fait ce film qui
ont voté du coup ce qui compliquait
votre tâche
en revanche vous avez loupé le coche à
saint rémy les chevreuse et une une
élection partielle dans les yvelines
ç'aurait pu être potentiellement votre
première victoire dans une mairie en
france finalement vous loupé le coche à
22 voix près à 22 voix près seulement
est ce que c'est un échec
las de voir que peut-être au bout de six
mois on se dit que la république en
marche
ce n'est pas si attirants en fait c'est
pas un échec parce que c'était vraiment
des personnes novices en politique des
personnes qui étaient complètement pas
du tout connu et c'était vraiment des
personnes issues de la société civile
qui se lançait une première fois en
politique et qui ont aujourd'hui une
place au conseil mais ça va marcher pour
les élections législatives cette
nouveauté on ne connaissait pas béatrice
piron député de la 3e circonscription
des yvelines on ne connaissait pas nadia
et là ça va marcher
lorsqu'on compte qu'on ne connaît pas le
candidat de la république en marche qui
a perdu face à dominique bavol élu lui
ça veut dire que la recette peut aussi
parfois ne pas marcher concrètement vous
en rendez compte ou non moi je pense que
c'était des élections très local et qui
pour une première avec des personnes qui
n'étaient pas du tout connu du paysage
politique restent très encourageantes en
matière de résultats et shahinez taleb
rester avec nous on passe tout de suite
à l'actualité de la semaine
les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine ne
lâche pas et persistent dans leur projet
de rapprochement après l'archéologie et
l'adoption notamment l'entretien des
routes pendant la période hivernale
devient une gestion mutualisée entre les
deux collectivités
près de 170 agences sont ainsi déployés
sur les routes jusqu'à la fin de l'hiver
pour faire face aux intempéries elles
les précisions avec ce reportage
1500 km de voirie à entretenir ensemble
durant tout l'hiver
le rapprochement entre les départements
des yvelines et des hauts-de-seine passe
son premier test neige et verglas avec
une mise en commun des moyens humains et
matériels pour assurer une circulation
optimale jusqu'à la fin de l'hiver dans
les yvelines
nous sommes habitués à des hivers
compliqué enneigées et donc on a une
organisation territoriale très très
pertinente et performante par rapport à
ça les hauts-de-seine eux ont une
organisation différente puisque c'est un
département plus petits plus ramassé
plus urbain plus de 30 saleuses 4000
tonnes de sel et 169 agents mobilisables
jusqu'en mars
les moyens sont importants pour assurer
la bonne circulation le département des
yvelines pour un notamment profité du
système si terre est développée chez son
voisin depuis 20 ans une technologie qui
permet un fonctionnement plus efficace
des feux et des carrefours
on a mis en place un réseau de capteurs
dans la chaussée qui permettent de
vérifier en permanence le trafic
la quantité trafic et les taux de
congestion et à partir de ces données en
fait le pcsi terre envoie vers les
automates qui cherchent et qui il faut
faire fonctionner les feux tricolores
des ordres de tendre vers pour chacun
des mouvements des temps de parcours
réduits moins de pollution le système 6
ter sera déployé dans un premier temps
dans le nord des yvelines ce dispositif
là nous sommes en train progressivement
d'étudier son extension dans les
yvelines et en particulier sur les
secteurs les plus denses comme c'est
laval en 2016 les équipes voirie des
deux départements réaliser 200
interventions préventives
la mutualisation des moyens a pour but
également de démontrer l'intérêt d'une
fusion entre les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine
une fusion toujours suspendus aux
annonces du gouvernement sur la
métropole du grand paris chaîné taleb je
vais pas vous faire réagir sur
l'entretien des routes pendant l'hiver
mais sur cette problématique du
rapprochement 78,92 parce que c'est
aussi ça le but de cette mutualisation
c'est de continuer à approuver que ça
marche
ce rapprochement entre les deux
départements on croit comprendre que le
gouvernement n'est pas forcément
favorable à ce rapprochement que tout
dépend aussi de la métropole du grand
paris des décisions qui seront prises
quelle est votre position à vous vous
qui venez du nord du département ce que
vous soyez favorable à ce rapprochement
avec les hauts-de-seine alors moi je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut prendre les
choses dans l'ordre et que chaque chose
en son temps
je pense que dans les yvelines nous
sommes justement en pleine réflexion par
rapport au grand paris pour savoir
comment cela va s'articuler comment cela
va se dessiner et je pense qu'il est
important d'aller à la rencontre des
yvelinois et dehimi noise pour savoir
quelle est leur perception par rapport à
ce sujet de rapprochement qui n'est pas
à l'ordre du jour c'est vraiment de
procéder étape par étape d'abord la
métropole du grand paris et après
éventuellement selon les frontières de
la métropole du grand paris
rapprochement ou pas c'est ça le le
calendrier grossièrement exactement fait
moi enfin autre idée vraiment au niveau
du
du mouvement la réplique en marche dans
les yvelines c'est d'aller écouter ce
que les personnes ont à nous dire donc
récemment il ya deux semaines nous et on
nous étions sur les marchés un peu
partout dans le département des yvelines
avec un questionnaire sur le grand paris
pour savoir qu'est ce que les yvelinois
en pensez et pour commencer à réfléchir
sur justement ces différentes
thématiques mais encore une fois chaque
chose en son temps je pense qu'un temps
de consultation on n'aura pas de réponse
en tout cas arrêter aujourd'hui on a
bien compris exactement
merci shine est à l'aide est revenue en
plateau d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes là ferrand la
référente du coût de la république en
marche dans les yvelines
merci à vous merci à vous et puis bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année aussi dans le reste
de l'actualité cette semaine un outil
pour faciliter le travail des gendarmes
dont le département depuis novembre ils
sont équipés de smartphones avec
l'application n'est aux gens de la
technologie leur permet notamment de
vérifier plus plus rapidement certaines
informations lors de contrôles sur le
terrain
reportage sur le terrain justement de
nicolas landry contrôler la conformité
d'un permis de conduire vérifier
l'identité d'une personne à travers les
fichiers des missions effectuées avec un
smartphone par les gendarmes
c'est le dispositif n'est aux gens de le
nouvel outil technologique distribuer à
la gendarmerie nationale des yvelines
pour contrôler les véhicules donc c'est
toujours dans la même application sauf
que du coup on va aller d'un véhicule et
donc on va cochet fauvet ce véhicule
donc pour voir si c'est pas un véhicule
volé et le système d'immatriculation
dans l'élite
et voilà donc ensuite directement par le
lecteur de la bande
j'ai toutes les informations une
technologie utile dans la relation avec
les citoyens dans le cadre de
l'opération tranquillité vacances les
gendarmes géolocalise sur le smartphone
les maisons à surveiller vérification
des fenêtres des portails pour prévenir
des effractions
donc du coup une fois que tout ça c'est
terminé et qu'il n'y a rien à signaler
nous entrons dans l'application donc
notre passage et ça envoie directement
au propriétaire du domicile 1-1 email
lui disant qu'il n'y a rien à signaler
dans sa maison et que nous sommes bien
passé faciliter le travail entre le
terrain et la caserne avec une évolution
technologique d'un ordinateur portable
au début des années 2000 à une tablette
numérique des technologies collective on
passe à un outil individualisé à chaque
gendarme son smartphone il y à le mée
manteau de la police route donc qui
intègre l'ensemble des infractions qu'on
est susceptible de rencontrer à l'issue
sa part directement au centre de rennes
qui prend en compte la gestion finale
des du relevé d'infraction les
infractions répertoriés possèdent leurs
références aux textes législatifs ou
réglementaires avec les sanctions
encourues
ce nouvel outil technologique s'inscrit
dans les réflexions en cours sur la
réforme de la police de sécurité du
quotidien voulue par le gouvernement
lundi élus et professionnels ont
inauguré le nouveau bâtiment de
l'hôpital gérontologique et médico
social de plaisir et l'accueil les
services de médecine gériatrique et de
la rééducation ouverture qui a pour
ambition aussi de donner un nouveau
souffle à l'établissement et faciliter
le travail du personnel soignant les
précisions avec ce reportage de léa rêve
c'est une nouvelle ère pour les hôpitaux
de plaisir depuis lundi 18 décembre la
ville héberge officiellement le nouveau
bâtiment de l'hôpital gérontologique et
médico social ce bâtiment il est fait
il est consacré principalement à la
gériatrie et il permet de traiter les
personnes âgées en situation de
de fragilité tente en hospitalisation
dans les premier et deuxième étages que
en ambulatoire ici dans le
rez-de-chaussée moderne et fonctionnel
l'objectif du bâtiment faciliter le
travail des aides soignants au premier
étage les postes de soins peuvent
accueillir 120 lits au rez de chaussée
le service de jour peut lui prendre en
charge une trentaine de patients les
élus ont fait acte de présence gérard
larcher joséphine coleman berger
l'occasion pour eux d'exprimer les
ambitions du centre hospitalier mesurer
aujourd'hui les plus de 60 ans c'est 15
millions
bientôt 24 et donc du défi à relever on
passe dans le 21e siècle
on est dans un accompagnement du patient
qui est vraiment optimum 120 millions
d'euros c'est le coût de ce projet
d'innovation qui promet de ne pas
s'arrêter là puisque le centre
hospitalier de jean martin charcot et de
l' hôpital gérontologique et médico
sociales vont fusionner l'objectif de la
fusion c'est pas simplement de faire des
économies c'est d'apporter un meilleur
service est un service de qualité
il le fait par exemple il est
l'équipement scanner et irm
c'est le symbole d'un service
supplémentaire
l'établissement deviendra ainsi le
deuxième centre hospitalier du sud des
yvelines derrière versailles
le rapprochement des hôpitaux prendra
effet dès le 1er janvier 2018 plaisir
encore et toujours dans l'actualité
locale cette semaine avec un projet un
peu particulier autour du handicap le
théâtre eurydice esat a proposé lundi un
théâtre participatif des scènes jouées
devant les spectateurs qui sont devenus
eux mêmes acteurs à un moyen de lutter
contre les préjugés et de désamorcer
certaines situations compliquées et
camille lambert
bien sûr l'arrivée d'un nouveau collègue
dans une entreprise une étape parfois
inquiétante pour les salariés et si les
mots sont mal choisis la situation peut
vite déraper
j'ai rien contre l'accueil d'entreprises
de services c'est un théâtre
participatif
c'est un théâtre à visée pédagogique le
principe c'est qu'on a répété des scènes
assez courte avec des comédiens et ses
scènes s'arrête toujours sur un conflit
sur un sur un problème
ensuite on donne la parole au public
pour commenter ces scènes essayer de que
le public essaye de comprendre comment
le conflit est arrivé quelle est la
position de chaque personnage un théâtre
forum créé par la compagnie le jour se
lève avec les comédiens de lézat théâtre
eurydice de plaisir chacun d'eux est en
situation de handicap le rend a rejoint
la troupe eurydice il ya six mois
atteint d'anxiété sociale ce projet lui
tient à coeur
avant tout on est des êtres humains
qu'on a des compétences n'est pas défini
que par notre handicap qui
dans le
ba s'est joué
notre personne que soi même d'ailleurs
qu'on peut le théâtre on peut venir qui
ont votre recruteur acteurs
médico-sociaux et membres d'associations
le public a pu échanger tout l'après
midi
d'autres séances seront programmées en
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo le
dernier de la saison il me reste à vous
souhaiter de joyeuses fêtes à tous la
magie d'ailleurs s'installe sur tv 78
pendant les fêtes avec une émission
spéciale préparée par l'ensemble de la
rédaction en plateau des auteurs
artistes et magicien mais aussi plein
d'idées de cadeaux ou vos pires
souvenirs de noël on en a tous une
émission qui sera retrouvée pour une
première diffusion samedi 23 décembre à
21h ou encore lundi 25 décembre à 19
heures le retour de l'information se
fera lui mardi 2 janvier à 18h sur tv 78
excellente fête à tous
[Musique]